كيف يمكن تهدئه الوضع على المستوى الدولي
اذا ما نشرنا المزيد من الوعي
واذا ما اصغى القاده
[موسيقى]
لهذا الاشخاص الذين يرفعون اصواتهم
واذا ما اطلعنا على الادله العلميه في
اليهود وكذلك كل عوامل المؤثره على حياه
البشر واذا ما حاولنا ان نجعل عالمنا
مكانا افضل
عبر اتخاذ القرارات الجيده اي تلك
العلاقات المرتبطه بحياه البشر
فبامكاننا ان نهدئ التوترات
وبلا شكوى بهذا الخصوص
فان المنظمات الدوليه المتعدده يجب ان
تلعب ادوار
رياديه من ضمنها المتحده وحتى المنظمات
الاخرى
يجب ان تقوم بعمل اكبر
لتهدئه تلك التوترات
بين الدول
نفهم بانه ساعه القيامه هذه كل ما اقتربت
من الثانيه عشره منتصف الليل وكانه يرتفع
خط الخطر الى اللون الاحمر هل حصل انه من
عام 45 من وقت انشاء هذه الساعه حتى الان
او من قبل ذلك ان تراجعنا عن بدلا من ان
نتقدم نحو منتصف الليل هل حصل انه تقدمنا
وتراجعنا الى الخلف
في الحقيقه عندما بدات عام 1947 بدات من
سبع دقائق
وكل ما نعرفه من تاريخنا فالانسانيه كانت
قريبه جدا من نقطه حرجه عندما حصلت ازمه
الصواريخ الكوبيه وحصر ذلك في عام 1962
وبعد عام 63 تم اعداد ساعه يوم القيامه
ولكن عندما
حلت تلك الازمه ازمه الصواريخ الكوبيه عبر
السبل السلميه
واتخذت الانسان انفاسا عميقه وبالتالي فقد
اعيد ضبطها على سبع دقائق
وايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده عندما وقعوا معاهده
الاسلحه النوويه حول خطي الاسلحه النوويه
وكذلك منع وحظر التجارب النوويه
فالضبطت الساعات الى 17 دقيقه في عام 91
ومن ذلك الوقت وساعه يوم القيامه لم
تتراجع دائما اقتربت من منتصف الليل
ولهذا اليوم اليوم بالتحديد وصلت الى
اقرب ما يمكن وهذا يعني باننا بحاجه الى
المزيد من التظافر والتعاون والتفاهم
والادله العلميه واضحه اعتقد بي ان الادله
علميه ليست مرتبطه باي قوميه وليست محليه
بل هي عالميه
وعندما ضبطوا الساعات يوم القيامه الى مئه
ثانيه في عام 2020
اعتقد بانها كانت دقيقه جدا فاذا ما
اطلعنا الى نزاعي في اوكرانيا
والجائحه
فاعتقدوا بان هذا التوقيت الدقيق جدا
وتقريبها عشر ثواني اليوم
ايضا
توقيت دقيقه خاصه اذا ما اصغينا الى
الخبراء او الذين قدموا الادله العلميه
فالامر منطقي جدا
الان الامر كله بيدي اصحاب القرار
بالعمل
ونشر الوعي وعليهم ان يفكروا بساعه يوم
القيامه من اجل ابعادها عن منتصف الليل